Traduttore: Claude Almansi
Revisore: Emanuela Abate
(Applausi)
Già.
Perché in carcere non si lavora?
Fare questa domanda a esperti,
economisti, ricercatori,
rappresentanti delle istituzioni,
e, oggi, anche a voi,
fa parte del mio lavoro.
Sì, perché io lavoro in un carcere.
Devo ammettere che, siccome
non ho commesso reati,
alla sera posso uscire e tornare a casa.
Lavoro in carcere da nove anni,
qui a Torino,
all'Istituto Lorusso e Cutugno,
che, per gli amici,
è il Carcere delle Vallette,
dove coordino le attività
di una cooperativa sociale,
in una sezione maschile
e presso la sezione femminile.
Oggi proverò a raccontarvi
qual è la mia idea di carcere.
Il carcere è visto spesso
come un luogo buio, fastidioso,
di cui non ci vogliamo occupare.
È un po' come certe vecchie
e brutte cantine di casa nostra,
dove mettiamo quello
che vogliamo nascondere,
che non ci interessa più,
quello che è rotto o corrotto.
E il verbo marcire
è spesso associato al carcere.
"Dovrebbe marcire in galera", si urla,
magari anche a ragione.
Peccato che, a far marcire
le persone in carcere,
si fa dispetto più alla società civile
che a quella incivile.
È perché tenere una persona
per lungo tempo in carcere,
senza fare nulla,
significa che probabilmente uscirà
peggiore di come ci è entrato.
Oggi, in Italia, ci sono
quasi 55.000 detenuti.
Di questi, il 34% è in attesa
di una sentenza di condanna definitiva.
È un sistema che costa al nostro Paese
tre miliardi di Euro all'anno.
Significa 140 Euro al giorno
per ciascun detenuto.
E, poi, c'è questo dato,
quello della recidiva.
La percentuale di chi ricade,
di chi torna in carcere
dopo aver già commesso altri reati.
Non ci sono statistiche ufficiali,
perché è un dato complesso da calcolare.
Ma validi e affidabili studi empirici,
ci dicono che la percentuale
oscilla tra il 60% e il 75%.
È troppo.
È troppo perché, capite, che il carcere
rischia di diventare, e diventa,
un sistema di porte girevoli,
un continuo entrare e uscire,
entrare e uscire,
che ha costi sociali ed economici
troppo elevati.
Di certo, la sicurezza dei cittadini
non migliora.
E si finisce per alimentare
una fabbrica di manodopera,
a disposizione di un'economia illegale,
della criminalità comune o, peggio ancora,
della criminalità organizzata.
Proverò a dimostrarvi
che è possibile immaginare
un'idea di carcere diverso.
D'altra parte, anche le cantine,
quelle di cui parlavo prima,
possono cambiare nel tempo.
Sul catalogo di una nota azienda svedese,
ce ne sono di molto belle.
Sembrano quasi appartamenti.
E capita che qualcuno guardi meglio
nella propria cantina,
e possa scovare un Rembrandt,
o un mobile di grande valore.
A volte, basta guardare le cose
con un occhio diverso.
La stessa cosa dovremmo cominciare
a farla con il carcere,
guardarlo come un luogo di opportunità
per chi lo abita
e di minor peso per tutti noi.
Portare lavoro in carcere, è una grande,
difficile sfida,
ma se la raccogliamo, può portare
più sicurezza per i cittadini,
più risorse umane a disposizione
di una società sana,
più economia legale, meno sprechi.
Oggi, nelle carceri italiane,
i detenuti che lavorano per imprese
e cooperative sociali,
sono meno di 2.500.
È il 4,5% di tutta
la popolazione detenuta.
Per queste persone, la recidiva,
di cui parlavamo prima,
si abbatte in maniera clamorosa.
Scende sotto il 20%.
E, se al lavoro, associamo
le misure alternative al carcere,
questa percentuale si abbassa
ulteriormente.
Le misure alternative al carcere,
come la detenzione domiciliare,
la semilibertà
che consente alle persone
di uscire dal carcere al mattino,
andare a lavorare
e farvi ritorno alla sera.
L'affidamento in prova significa
rispettare certe prescrizioni,
non frequentare pregiudicati,
certi locali,
rientrare entro una certa ora
e svolgere attività positive,
di utilità e di mediazione sociale,
financo risarcire le vittime,
le vittime, di cui troppo spesso
ci dimentichiamo.
Le imprese e le cooperative
che lavorano nelle carceri
si trovano in tutta Italia,
da Aosta a Palermo.
E cercano di sviluppare progetti
e sinergie positive con i territori,
riscoprendo le tradizioni artigiane
di cui è ricco il nostro paese,
valorizzandone
le eccellenze enogastronomiche.
In Italia l'ironia non manca mai,
ci contraddistingue come popolo.
E l'ironia c'è anche in prigione.
Vi racconto qualche nome di quei prodotti,
di quegli oggetti ambasciatori
che raccontano di un buon carcere.
A Verbania c'è la Banda Biscotti
ma invece di pianificare rapine
sfornano eccellenti biscotti
di pasticceria.
Qui a Torino c'è un pane
dal nome truffaldino
"Farina nel sacco"
e vi consiglio di assaggiarlo.
A Venezia si recupera il PVC
con cui si fanno delle borse,
le "Malefatte."
Ma detto fra noi, sono fatte benissimo.
E dalla Sicilia arrivano dei prodotti
a base di mandorle,
che si chiamano "Dolci evasioni."
(Risate)
E c'è anche chi si chiama
"Sprigioniamo sapori."
ma vuole soltanto liberare torroni
e creme di pistacchio.
Al di là dei nomi, dell'ironia,
quello che è importante
è che le imprese, le cooperative
possano offrire alle persone
che hanno svolto e seguito
un percorso meritevole
una proposta seria,
continuativa,
equamente retribuita,
professionalizzante,
perché in carcere si impara un mestiere;
una proposta che consenta alle persone
di tracciare traiettorie migliori
per il proprio futuro,
per quando usciranno dalla prigione.
Lavorare in carcere significa
sperimentare relazioni sane,
dare un senso a quel tempo,
ricostruire un ponte con la società, là,
fuori.
Il lavoro in carcere
può rendere quel posto
un luogo da cui si esce migliori
di come ci si è entrati.
Portare lavoro in carcere
è un progetto ambizioso
e ha bisogno del contributo di tutti:
delle cooperative che devono lavorare
in primis in maniera seria,
imparare a stare sul mercato;
delle istituzioni che devono accogliere
i progetti più virtuosi;
della società civile e di tutti noi
che possiamo accogliere
queste opportunità.
E poi c'è bisogno di una diversa
visione del futuro.
Ecco, provate a immaginare
cosa succederebbe
se tra dieci anni in Italia lavorasse
il 90% della popolazione detenuta.
Avremmo un carcere diverso,
un carcere con meno persone,
con le persone che hanno commesso
i reati più gravi,
che scontano una pena certa.
E così potremmo anche risparmiare un po'
di quei tre miliardi di Euro
di cui dicevo prima
e avere più sicurezza, davvero,
nel nostro quotidiano.
Infine, quindi, portare lavoro in carcere
è una grande idea,
è un'idea vincente,
è un'idea rivoluzionaria.
Però vi devo confessare
che non l'abbiamo inventata noi.
L'abbiamo copiata.
E sapete da chi?
Dalla Costituzione
della Repubblica Italiana,
Articolo 27, Comma 3:
"Le pene non possono consistere in
trattamenti contrari al senso di umanità
e devono tendere alla rieducazione
del condannato."
Grazie
(Applausi)